Ellen DeGeneres on the time she ended up
in the hospital Ellen had Claire Danes
on her talk show Tuesday
but before chatting with the homeland
actress she hilariously revealed why she
was wearing a splint on her finger I
broke my finger so you know how in
gymnastics when you do a one-handed
cartwheel and you have to spread the
weight evenly between all your fingers
well I had two glasses of wine and fell
into a door yep that was enough for her
wife Portia to drive the talk-show host
to the emergency room I just caught the
the lip of the top step I was like a
foot away from the door and I fell into
the door and I it did something to my
finger cuz I knew something was wrong I
looked at my finger and this is what it
looked like and oh I should have warned
you and so don't look at that if you're
squeamish don't look at it I should have
warned I'm sorry I dislocated my finger
that's what they call it which is an
incorrect term because I knew where it
was located before they did it I was in
incredible pain and Tammy said do you
want a shot and I said no I had two
glasses of wine
what got me into this mess in the first
place Tammi she meant a shot to numb my
finger
[Music]